>>> THE FORMER PRESIDENT'S ONCE
CLOSE RELATIONIP WITH WHITE
EVANGELICALS A BEDROCK OF HIS
2016 RISE THROUGH THE PRIMARIES
INTO THE PRESIDENCY APPEARS TO
BE FRAYING.
ON MONDAY HE SPOKE IN A
CONSERVATIVE BROADCAST AND
LASHED OUT AT EVANGELICAL
LEADERS FOR NOT ALREADY
ENDORSING HIS LATEST BID FOR THE
WHITE HOUSE.
>> A SIGN OF DISLOYALTY.
THERE IS GREAT DISLOYALTY IN THE
WORLD OF POLITICS AND THAT IS A
SIGN OF DISLOYALTY BECAUSE
NOBODY AS YOU KNOW AND YOU WOULD
KNOW BETTER THAN ANYBODY BECAUSE
YOU DO SUCH A GREAT JOB, NOBODY
HAS EVER DONE MORE FOR RIGHT TO
LIFE THAN DONALD TRUMP.
>> DURING THE SAME INTERVIEW HE
APPEARED TO DEFLECT THE BLAME HE
AND HIS HAND PICKED CANDIDATES
RECEIVED FOR REPUBLICANS'
UNDERWHELMING PERFORMANCE IN THE
MIDTERM SAYING EVANGELICALS
COULD HAVE FOUGHT MUCH HARDER.
WHAT DO YOU THINK OF THIS FIRST
OF ALL THE, DOES IT MAKE SENSE
HE WOULD GO ON RECORD KINED OF
CRITICIZING EVANGELICALS FOR NOT
BEING LOYAL ENOUGH?
>> IT IS ALMOST NATURAL THAT HE
WOULD BRING UP SO AND SO
CRITICIZED YOU THAT IS HIS KIND
OF AUTOMATIC RESPONSE, KIND OF A
REACTION FOR HIM.
FOR THIS THOUGH IT IS NOTABLE
BECAUSE THAT WAS SUCH A KEY BLOC
IN 2016.
THEY HELPED HIM ALSO IN 2020.
EVANGELICAL VOTERS HELPED PUT
TRUMP IN THE WHITE HOUSE.
I WAS TALKING TO SEVERAL OF HIS
FORMER ADVISERS AND THEY WERE
SAYING THEY VIEW IT AS KIND OF
SELF-DEFEATING.
THEY ARE NOT TOTALLY SURPRISED
BY IT BECAUSE IT COMES AS HE IS
HAVING THESE BROADER FEARS ABOUT
WHAT THE 2024 FIELD IS GOING TO
LOOK LIKE.
HE DOESN'T LIKE THE IDEA ANYONE
IS CHALLENGING HIM BUT TO HEAR
HIM GO AFTER THEM AND ALSO TO
SAY THEY DIDN'T FIGHT HARD
ENOUGH IN THE 2022 MIDTERM
ELECTIONS SAYING THAT BASICALLY
ONCE THE SUPREME COURT HAD
OVERTURNED ROE VS. WADE WHICH IS
OBVIOUSLY SOMETHING THAT
MOTIVATED THEM TO GO TO THE
POLLS FOR SO LONG, PEOPLE I WAS
SPEAKING TO WERE SAYING IT IS
SELF-DEFEATING FOR HIM TO GO
AFTER THAT GROUP THAT HELPED HIM
SO MUCH AFTER THE ONE WIN WHICH
IS WHY THEY SAID THEY PUT HIM IN
THE WHITE HOUSE TO APPOINT
CONSERVATIVE JUDGES.
>> HE DID DELIVER FOR
EVANGELICAL VOTERS WHETHER HE
TRULY BELIEVED IN WHAT HE WAS
DOING OR NOT.
HE DID DELIVER WHAT HE SAID HE
WOULD WHICH MANY OTHER
POLITICIANS, REPUBLICANS HAD
PROMISED TO EVANGELICAL VOTERS
OFFER THE YEARS IN PRESIDENTIAL
RACES AND NOT ACTUALLY DELIVERED
ON.
BUT IT WAS ALWAYS SORT OF A
MARRIAGE OF CONVENIENCE.
WHEN YOU HAVE MIKE PENCE RUNNING
FOR PRESIDENT, IT IS OBVIOUS WHY
A LOT OF EVANGELICALS IF HE
COULD WIN WOULD PROBABLY PREFER
HIM.
>> ANDERSON, FORGIVE ME.
I LOST YOU FOR A SECOND SO I MAY
NOT HAVE GOTTEN YOUR FULL
QUESTION BUT I WAS LISTENING TO
WHAT KAITLAN WAS SAYING EARLIER.
I THINK THE REALITY HERE IS THAT
THIS IS, POLITICS IS NOT THE
MOB.
IT IS NOT ALL ABOUT LOYALTY.
IT IS ABOUT WINNING.
EVANGELICAL LEADERS IN
PARTICULAR SAW THAT TRUMP LOST
THE 2020 ELECTION AND NOW THEY
HAVE OTHER CHOICES AND NONE OF
THEM WANT TO GET ON BOARD WITH A
LOSING TRAIN BEFORE THEY
ACTUALLY SEE WHAT THE OPTIONS
ARE HERE.
I THINK THAT HELPS KIND OF
EXPLAIN THE ACTIONS OF A LOT OF
THESE LEADERS.
YOU KNOW, KAITLAN IS RIGHT.
THIS WAS AN IMPORTANT BLOC FOR
TRUMP, FOR ANY CONSERVATIVE
CANDIDATE.
HE WORKED REALLY HARD PUTTING
OUT A LETTER SAYING I'LL
NOMINATE THESE JUDGES IF YOU
ELECT ME.
HE DID A LOT OF THINGS TO MAKE
SURE HE HAD TRUST FROM THAT
GROUP.
BUT THE REALITY IS THAT TRUST
WAS BROKEN WHEN HE LOST AND THEY
KNOW THAT IT IS UNLIKELY HE
POTENTIALLY IS GOING TO WIN THE
WHITE HOUSE AGAIN OR COULD
POTENTIALLY BE THE TOUGHEST
HORSE TO GET BEHIND HERE.
>> KAITLAN, I INTERVIEWED BART
BARBER THE PRESIDENT OF THE
SOUTHERN BAPTIST CONVENTION A
WHILE BACK FOR A "60 MINUTES"
PROFILE.
HE IS A VERY STRAIGHT FORWARD
GUY, NOT A MEGACHURCH PASTOR,
HEAD OF NOW THE LARGEST
EVANGELICAL ORGANIZATION.
HE CLEARLY SAID HE WOULD BACK
PENCE IN A PRIMARY.
HE WOULD HAVE NO PROBLEM.
AND OBVIOUSLY IN A GENERAL HE
WAS SAYING WE'LL SEE WHO THE
OTHER CANDIDATES ARE.
BUT THE FACT THERE ARE OTHER
REPUBLICANS IN THE RACE WHOSE
MORALITY NOT ONLY SUPPORT THE
SAME POLICIES TRUMP SUPPORTED
BUT WHOSE MORALITY IS NOT AS
QUESTIONABLE AS TRUMP'S, IT'S
UNDERSTANDABLE WHY SOME
EVANGELICAL LEADERS WOULD BE
HOPING THOSE WOULD RISE.
>> IF TIM SCOTT GETS IN THE RACE
YOU COULD SEE WHO THEIR
PREFERRED CANDIDATE WOULD BE.
OBVIOUSLY THE GUY WHO
SAID TWO CORINTHIANS --
>> ARE HE NEVER ASKED FOR
FORGIVENESS.
THEY WANTED A POINT CONSERVATIVE
JUDGES TO THE SUPREME COURT WHO
WOULD OVERTURN ROE VERSUS WADE
AND GIVEN HIS FEUD WITH MITCH
McCONNELL, A KEY PERSON IN THAT.
I THINK IT'S CLEAR THAT IS WHY
THEY'RE LOOKING AT IT THIS WAY.
IT'S NOT JUST THAT PASTOR AS
WELL BUT LOOK AT JON ROBINSON,
HE WAS CRITICAL OF TRUMP IN THE
FALL SAYING HE WAS LIKE AN
ELEMENTARY SCHOOL KID.
HE WOULD TRY TO GIVE HIM ADVICE
AND STOP TWEETING, STOP TALKING
AND SHOOTING OFF THE HIP,
SHOOTING FROM THE HIP, AND HE
WOULD CONTINUE TO DO SO.
YOU'VE SEEN ROBERT JEFFRESS WHO
SAID I'LL SUPPORT WHO THE
NOMINEE IS AND SUPPORT TRUMP IF
HE'S THE NOMINEE BUT MAKING
CLEAR HE WON'T NECESSARILY GET
INVOLVED AND RON DeSANTIS'
CAMPAIGN AD WHERE THEY WERE SAY
GOD NEEDED A FIGHTER, A
PROTECTOR SO HE MADE RON
DeSANTIS -- THEY ARE GOING FOR
THAT GROUP.
>> RIGHT.
KASIE, MIKE PENCE HAS A BOOK
TOUR BASED IN EVANGELICAL
CHURCHES AROUND THE COUNTRY.
>> YEAH, HE SCHURR DOES AND HE'S
A VERY NATURAL CANDIDATE FOR
THIS GROUP.
THIS HAS BEEN KIND OF HIS ROCK
SOLID BLOC FOR HIS ENTIRE
POLITICAL CAREER.
NOW, THAT SAID, I THINK THERE
ARE A LOT OF QUESTIONS ACROSS
THE BOARD ABOUT, YOU KNOW, WHAT
PENCE'S CONSTITUENCY IS
CONSIDERING WHERE HE STANDS WITH
DONALD TRUMP AND, YOU KNOW, ONE
QUESTION I HAVE TALKING ABOUT
E
EVANGELICAL LEADERS.
THEIR FLOCK DOESN'T NECESSARILY
FOLLOW THEM ON THINGS LIKE THIS
AND, YOU KNOW, I'D BE INTERESTED
TO SEE IF ANY CONGREGATIONS
DON'T HARBOR A LOT THAT SUPPORT
TRUMP.
I THINK IT'S GOING TO BE MY
QUESTION AS WE HEAD INTO THE
CAMPAIGN SEASON.
AFTER THIS BECAUSE THAT WAS A
D
KEY BLOCK THAT HELPED DELIVER
THE WHITE HOUSE TO DONALD TRUMP.
THEY SAID THEY BELIEVE THIS IS A
SELF-DEFEATING ISSUE FOR TRUMP.
>> THIS IS AN OWN GOAL BUT I
THINK HE BLURTED OUT WHAT HE
BELIEVES.
REMEMBER LOYALTY WITH DONALD
TRUMP IS A ONE-WAY STREET.
BUT TO YOUR POINT, WHITE
EVANGELICALS VOTED FOR DONALD
TRUMP THAT VOTED FOR GEORGE W.
BUSH WHO IS ACTUALLY A
BORN-AGAIN CHRISTIANE.
-- BORN-AGAIN CHRISTIAN.
FOR HIM TO LASH OUT SAYING
THEY'RE DISLOYAL, DOES HE THINK
THEY'RE HIS PETS THAT CAN BE
CALLED TO HEEL?
WE HAVE A PROBLEM IN THIS
COUNTRY WITH THE POLARIZATION,
THE POLARIZATION OF RELIGIOUS
FAITHS AND THIS INSULT TO THE
COMMUNITY SAYING THEY HAVE TO
FALL IN LINE WHEN HE RUNS,
REMINDS US OF THE IMPORTANCE OF
KEEPING ELECTIONS SEPARATE FROM
RELIGION.
>> HE DID THE SAME THING WITH
JEWISH AMERICANS.
>> HE DID.
QUESTIONING THEIR LOYALTY
BECAUSE IN THAT TRUMP CENTRIC
UNIVERSE, IT'S ALL ABOUT WHAT'S
GOOD FOR DONALD TRUMP AND NOT
ACTUALLY THE E SSSENCE OF REACHG
O
OUT AND GETTING CONVERTS.
>> HE WAS SAYING BECAUSE OF ROE
V. WADE THEY DIDN'T COME OUT AS
MUCH HE BELIEVES IN THE MIDTERMS
AFTER IT WAS ALREADY OVERTURNED.
>> RELIGION AND POLITICS IS
COMPLICATED.
HE BLAMED THE OVERTURNING OF ROE
V. WADE FOR THE PERFORMANCE OF
2022 NOW SAYING HE WANTS CREDIT
FOR IT.
IN 2020 I INTERVIEWED A SERIES
OF RELIGIOUS LEADERS ABOUT THE
CHOICES, BIDEN BEING A PERSON OF
FAITH.
AND WAS REMINDED THE BIBLE WARNS
AGAINST THE SIN OF LYING OVER
116 TIMES.
SO IT SEEMS TO ME THOSE ARE
FACTORS YOU PUT IN PLACE
OVERTIME AND THE TOTALITY.
BUT BOTTOM LINE WE HAVE TO
BREAKDOWN THE POLARIZATION OF
FAITH IN AMERICAN POLITICS.
>> NEEDS TO GET OUT MORE.
>> THERE'S THAT TOO.
>> THANK YOU, JOHN.